[Music]
it becomes like a billboard right
and i it's true i hate the ocean
but i do
i do love the beach i love the beach
happy friday my friday fellows so i saw
something weird last night and for once
it wasn't in the mirror above my bed
after a night of heavy drinking i turned
on cnn and then i saw john king going
through some pretty bad numbers for the
president and none of them even involved
his iq
look at how bad these numbers are for
the president only four in 10 americans
41 at the moment approve of his job
performance nearly 6 in 10 58
disapproved that's a tough number early
in the midterm election year for the
president united states now why is this
happening this is fascinating we asked
people what has president biden done for
you that you approve of 56 percent of
americans nearly six in 10 americans
that means a decent amount of democrats
said nothing they disapprove of
everything that has happened
so that's amazing you know if you're
quiet enough you can hear jimmy carter
letting out a sigh of relief
because that's a lot of people who say
joe's done nothing for them and that's
coming from cnn so i would double it i
take everything i get from cnn and
double it including brian stelter's bmi
of course cnn defended joe pointing out
that he passed that infrastructure plan
and king worries that the good stuff joe
didn't did isn't really sinking in maybe
because like our olympic athletes we
can't name one
but also we're now a country plagued by
random crime hopeless violence inflation
government tracking and a disintegrating
border where is this good stuff that we
were promised
the same poll about cove but another 60
said they were angry and 75 were burned
out it's like joe has turned all of us
into the vp's former staffers
no wonder biden's minions are
desperately trying to pretend he's been
leading us all along the omicron variant
is in retreat
and that's not by accident
that's because under president biden's
leadership
a public health infrastructure was put
into place to ensure that we can do
everything possible to crush the virus
whether there should be blanket mandates
for businesses and and other uh public
public areas is is a step that here in
new york we feel comfortable taking
because of the success of the
president's policies
nice try you see what's happening as the
pandemic comes to a close they want
credit for closing it it's like when you
help push a car that's out of gas and
there's always one guy who's just
pretending to grunt that's this
administration all noise no pushing
but you know it's bad when even bakari
seller says it's bad
when can americans expect some relief
from this soaring inflation according to
nobel laureates 14 of them that
contacted me and a number of corporate
leaders it's ought to be able to start
to taper off as we go through this year
yeah it was a terrible answer and i i
would i would tell them that if they
were looking me in the face the fact is
that nobody that scott and i are talking
about want to hear what nobel laureates
actually say about the problem in fact
in that answer we would care more about
the solution
he'd say it but he's right citing nobel
laureates while price is sore it's like
jerry nadler and skinny jeans it's not a
good look
yeah as if you're gonna feel better when
you ask the cashier why you're paying 16
bucks for two pork chops and she says
don't worry paul krugman says prices
will be back to normal next year
and it makes you wonder why this almost
only happens under democrats well
because thanks to some of the disciples
in the media they can
check out this npr headline it reads
inflation hits another 40-year high it's
bad but older folks say they've seen
worse
now technically they could be right if
they were talking about pearl harbor the
hindenburg or scrunchies but imagine if
you use the it's been worse excuse about
climate change or racism
yet they use it on crime and inflation
the things that affect the poor and
working class and minorities that they
claim to protect look on the bright side
it's not an all-time high for murder
just a 25-year high
right now as inflation rises so does
mass theft which is close closing stores
and forcing remaining businesses to lock
up their goods and then raise more
prices prices are so high i was in a cvs
in times square and i saw jesse waters
slipping three boxes of rogaine into his
pants
it's no wonder there's yet another
horrible poll for for joe according to
pew only one in five americans believe
he will ever be successful but this
doesn't even register with joe who's
busy competing with kamala for who wants
to be seen less
so the reason why americans think joe is
doing nothing for them is because he's
doing nothing for them and his own loony
left whom he relies on now for
everything
thinks the public concerns are laughable
al sharpton of all people says the
government must end the crime wave and
he got mocked for it by the left he was
complaining how drug stores have to lock
up toothpaste now and really the last
thing we want is someone with a mouth as
big as his not to brush his teeth
but lefty fiction writer nicole hannes
jones says who cares there's always been
theft also coming out against
shoplifting only encourages the prison
state and here i thought the left was
okay with china
so we're at weird times when suddenly al
sharpton sounds like william f buckley
i wonder what joe has to say
hey boy i got to talk about this on a
friday come on
greg gutfeld he's a wise guy but you
know he says that's his job so you know
you got to live with it
i agree with hannah nicole smith she's a
smart gal
look al sharpton
he knows crime's been around forever
that's part of the whole deal i mean
late 70s new york that's when he got his
start come on man the did you ever see
that movie taxi driver you talking to me
you talking to me
he was looking in the mirror that's the
whole thing he was talking to himself
those guys were great
they were fact is both dismissive
attitudes towards crime and inflation
are racist because both affect non-white
minorities more than anyone stores close
prices rise who can handle that besides
plywood salesmen well also rich whites
who just order off amazon or send their
assistance to another store so the dems
are screwed and they deserve it here's
why you can't obsess over woke concerns
and also fight crime or inflation the
hard left priorities have taken up all
the shelf space in joe's limited brain
so there's an opportunity cost to this
identity politics and ironically it's
affecting the identities that the left
claim to defend so you got an aimless
unconcerned president who seems to be
the only person that wants to go to
vacation in delaware in winter you got a
media and party trying to salvage a
dying administration and you have an
emboldened left who think crime is what
you deserve
remember when the press said this was
gonna be so much better than trump
who knew they meant better for murderers
thugs thieves and 2022 republican
candidates
let's welcome
tonight's guests
i call her atm because she's always
talking money host of the evening edits
on fox business
mcdonald's
he's an inspiration to the nation and
frankly i'd like it if he joined me on
vacation retired u.s marine bomb
technician and fox news contributor
johnny joey jo
this weekend she'll be smoking a super
bowl
fox news contributor count
and his high school senior picture is a
google earth photo my massive sidekick
at the nwa world television champion
almost fainted there liz yeah you did
yeah hyperventilate it's kind of fun for
a while then you get a little dizzy and
hot and sweaty you know
that sounds hot yeah you know the
safeword cat if he does that again
my safe word is more okay
which is why
no one is safe in my bedroom liz i'm
sitting right near you
you uh
have you seen much of this lester holt
video what did you make of it well you
know it's he was giving biden this
softball question using biden's own
words right you said it was going to be
transitory meanwhile sticking inflation
sticking around for seven months but
then you know i feel like i'm back in a
1930s gunmaul movie he's like hey you're
a wise guy
you're wise guy right it sounds like
east side comedy or it's like president
jimmy cagney yes you know so it was when
i saw it i thought weren't they going to
put the president out back on the
campaign trail to talk more right and
now he's yelling still he's still
yelling at people and now you've got
obama right obama's talking to house
democrats and nbc ran out of headline
this is unseemly of obama to do that
it's breaking norms for him to be
politicking so it feels like what
variant all of a sudden got into the
mainstream media to pick up what you've
been everybody's been saying for a while
about how weird and off the wall the
democrat party has been you have that's
a great analogy he is like the 1940s
gangster president like remember you
call that guy fat hey fatty
right remember that he was in that town
hall and that guy was like
fat yeah hey fat hey hey hey
hey hey hey who do you think you are
smart guy he does that to uh peter ducey
our very own people
and by the way his poll numbers are
dropping the fastest since
yes so you know yeah who brings you back
huh yeah he looks like he's in a vacuum
jonathan joey jones good to see you as
always
looks like you're letting yourself go
you know i had a long sleeve shirt and i
heard tyrus was gonna be on the night so
i cut the sleeves off and uh i got a
whole moment everybody's like is taurus
as big as he looks like you haven't seen
the guy stand up yeah i mean like yeah
all right put your tongue back in your
mouth
um i've never seen a match
of public sentiment for an actual leader
that actually fits perfectly right it's
generally saying they're too hard on
this person i think i think the right
was too hard on obama and i think the
left was too hard on trump but this is
like the what is it the goldilocks this
seat is perfect like they i think the
people actually get this guy does that
make sense at all
i guess i just wonder what his response
would be that was polite if lester
holden said is your son still smoking
crack
um you know was anything on the laptop
true yeah how much money is in your bank
account from uh foreign investors you
know like i mean there are hard-hitting
questions that are legitimate he
literally asked the man
inflation's still here what's a short
time what does transitory mean and the
dude was was befuddled he was all upset
about it yeah you're the president of
the united states you wanted this job
yeah people people die under your
command as a matter of fact apparently
you don't trust the people who uh take
people to war under your command anymore
there are people that care about you
answering questions and you're going to
call somebody a wise guy
it's repulsive
yeah you know we got big plans for the
super bowl tyrus yeah i'm gonna sit in
my movie theater and watch it yeah what
time should i be there and what do you
want me to bring
[Laughter]
uh the jet for the moon leaves around 3
p.m so uh be at jfk at 6 a.m i've
noticed that nobody can call nobody
invites me anymore to you you don't go
go oh that's not good
it doesn't first of all we live in
different states so it's a hell of a
commute you barely like driving home
yeah well that's true you know and then
you'll be like oh you'll say you're
going you'll plan you're going maybe
then you don't go and then you'll go oh
i got this thing i'm writing this stuff
i got a monologue
you know i got a
that thing with russia you know but in
defense
i don't know of that means yes you do
[Laughter]
the uh
the
nerve yes i'm gonna defend the president
on this go for it i mean who do you
think you are yeah asking me
stuff that i said before
[Laughter]
what i said i say a lot of stuff
come on man like i can't be asked to
remember what i said recently to be fair
he probably doesn't you know but
i greg
i told you this was going to happen you
did you predicted i said that they were
only wanted him to get in
and then the knives would come out for
their
chosen one who's sitting beside him not
doing anything and hiding so now they
agree with us yes now suddenly the the
jokes are and the comments are messed up
or before they were heartfelt and he had
a gaffed yeah small stutter now it's
like he's unfit
and he shouldn't be here and he's a
disgrace hmm yeah and they were like
they were waiting for kamala so we need
to go the opposite way and go
well he meant well yes his heart was in
it actually you're actually right we
should start defending him kat we should
start saying there's nothing wrong with
him he's doing a great job so they keep
him as the nominee
sure he's doing a great job
you're gonna need to act a little better
yeah i just can't
you didn't put any emotion into that
i do have that problem across the board
in my life
but i will you know because it's it's
like bare minimum he could do like
nobody actually thinks that inflation is
going to be having any real impact on
like the most powerful person in the
world he can at least pretend to
understand that it is a big deal for
some people rather than just say oh it's
this like academic ideal that he
discusses with his other rich or famous
friends just at least
you don't even have to care just
acknowledge
bare minimum
yeah like pound his fist be like damn it
yes yes yes
i don't know or get that mad whisper
going yeah yes it's just inflation
why do they always have to do this thing
at the super bowl anyway
right this when since when did this
become a tradition yeah why is it a
thing now i don't know
it's the last thing i want to do is
watch an interview with the president
when you know as a person who loves
football you know me oh yeah it runs in
your blood and you wouldn't know if you
had invited me to your super bowl party
but i don't have parties i watch the
game alone yeah well people always ask
me questions and i don't like catch with
tom brady in high school right that's
right i talked you teach him how to
catch i taught him how to count and when
he was crying and upset about getting
drafted in the first round it was you
that said don't worry brady i'll make a
call i know a guy named belichick will
figure something out i told him that
girls were pretty yeah and maybe he
should talk to them and lo and behold
just help bunching yeah
fair enough yeah didn't you call him up
after the game and say tom it's time
you're the one who called him said his
time tom that's what i did he you know
what uh i should call him after this
show just to see how he's what he said
maybe he'll watch the game with me
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else